So why don't we do gradient descent on y hat?
>> Well there could be many reasons but
the main reason is it's not differentiable. It's
a just discontinuous function. There's no way to
take the derivative at the point where it's discontinuous.
>> So this this activation thing. The, the change from.
Activation to y hat has this big step function jump in it, right, at zero.
So once the activation goes positive, actually at zero. It
jumps up to one. And before that, it's, it's not.
So the derivative is basically zero, and then that. Not
differentiable, and then zero again. So really, the zero's not giving
us any direction to push, in terms of how to
fix the weights. And the undefined part, of course, doesn't really
give us any information either. So this, this algorithm doesn't
really work, if you. Try to take the derivative through this
discontinuous function. But it does kind of, you
know. What if we made this, more differentiable? Like,
what is it that makes this so undifferentiable? It's
this, it's this really pointy spot, right. So you
could imagine a function that was kind of
like this, but then instead of the point spot,
it kind of smoothed out a bit. Mm, like that.
So kind of a softer version of a threshold,
which isn't exactly a threshold. But it leaks this differentiable.
>> Hm.
>> So that would kind of force the algorithm to put its
money where its mouth is. Like if that really is the reason, that
the problem is non differentiable, fine.
We'll make it differentiable. Now, how do
you like it? I don't know, how do we like it now [LAUGH]?
>> Well, I'll tell you how much I like it
when you show me a function that acts like that.